what you say is the difference between
lead actresses and their personality
traits portrayed in Indian cinema
versus American lead actresses actually
quite sort of quite sort of becoming
smaller I would say over the years I do
think women that's portrayed universally
there is you know it has still has to
improve but I do think that doesn't
matter where they're coming from there
are more challenging parts in India and
out and as opposed to in Hollywood and I
think it's a wonderful change so I think
the gap is getting smaller I would think
yes and what do you say to the the
recent ban on the film India I think
right now they have two weeks that
they're putting on it and some people
are calling it cultural terrorism
what would you say to that well I do
think join artists if you're a painter
musician filmmaker I do think you have
the right to be able to communicate with
the audience
your thoughts your your your you know
what you put you believe in and I
respect that it's it's the artistic
license that I think everybody should
have but you're an artist or not freedom
of speech is very important I think it's
it should be supported and protected yes
it appears that that Bollywood is so
enthusiastic about their actors and
actresses that it's almost like they're
royalty whereas in America they're
definitely enthusiastic but it doesn't
seem the same exuberance
so as great power comes a lot of
responsibility
you never yell wait to really make sure
that you send the right message and do
the right sort of thing so to speak
because you know you have so many people
depending on what you say that it's true
and on and I think films universally
they have a message I mean I've I've
actually seen films that have changed my
life so I think the medium itself is you
have a great responsibility and I hope
that everybody does right by it so yep